I'd like to call up first AC penny
[Applause]
um hello everybody
I am a current NCAA volleyball player so
I'm still in the middle of all those
early mornings everybody's talking about
um I'm also a young woman for America
Ambassador it is an absolute honor to
stand here today and celebrate with
y'all the passage of the protection of
women and girls in sports act through
the house uh thank you speaker McCarthy
for having me and Congressman Stewie for
sponsoring this bill
I worked my entire life to become an
NCAA athlete I was that girl in high
school who never got to go to prom who
never got to go on these fancy vacations
because I spent my weekends on the
volleyball court I would be traveling
around going to all of these various
Club tournaments to try and get
recruited and eventually realize my
dream of playing NCAA volleyball uh now
for the sake of including those who
cannot follow the most basic and
fundamental of roles that girls sports
are for girls only
female athletes who sacrificed so much
for their sport are being pushed out of
Athletics
sadly I have had to play my sport
volleyball against a male at one of
these volleyball tournaments while I was
trying to get recruited men's volleyball
nets are over seven inches higher than
female volleyball nets so this athlete
was playing on a net over seven inches
tall or seven inches shorter than he
should have as a man
if you can imagine trying to play
against somebody you know imagining
seven inches taller right it's a big
difference suddenly uh mediocre athletes
can hit like all Americans and that's
exactly what happened these college
recruiters were trying to evaluate my
skills and see if I would be a good fit
for their team and see these uh the work
that I put my entire life into and
instead they watched this boy slam the
ball in our face time and time again
um
a recruiter's job the recruiters who are
watching this game their ultimate job is
to bring titles and money back to their
school right well this can obviously
happen much easier with a biological
male in court so this ultimately strips
the opportunity of scholarships and
playing time an issue that was supposed
to have been settled 50 years ago with
the passage of Title IX
that is why I'm not going to be
assignment as a female athlete I see
what sports can do for women
Providence leadership training the
incredible experience of sacrificing for
a goal I will continue to speak up until
all female athletes everywhere have Fair
competitions
today's passage of the protection of
women and girls in sports Act is a great
step and I'm deeply grateful for
everyone standing up here who helped
make that happen thank you so much
thank you
and now let's hear from one of the very
first women to speak up with
courageousness talking about the
unfairness
[Applause]
to start speaking on this issue I was
forced to meet against two biological
males in track and field in my home
state of Connecticut I read I reached
against these athletes over a dozen
times and they would beat me out by 20
years in the 100 meter dash every single
time without fail I lost down on
countless opportunities most notably I
miss out on qualifying for the 2019
New England Regional meet I was kicked
out of the 55 meter finals and
qualifying for the New England meet by
the two biological males and I was
forced into the sidelines in my own
event because I was at the New England
meeting two other events where I
received all New England honors
I am eternally grateful for the House
Republicans for passing this bill to
ensure that no other girl has to
experience the pain and heartbreak that
I went through in my four years of high
school and I will review to them for the
rest of my life and I
know for as long as it takes thank you
thank you for your courage and now let's
hear from Taylor Silverman
[Applause]
what's going on my name is Taylor
Silverman and I have been skateboarding
now for almost 12 years and for the past
several years I have traveled around the
country competing in events in 2018 I
went to an event in California where I
was made aware that a male athlete was
in the women's division and then again
in 2020 when I traveled to Illinois the
same thing happened and the first couple
times this happened I honestly thought
that this was going to be a funny story
we laughed about one day and it would be
something everyone would agree was
obviously unfair and not the way to
handle it but unfortunately it continued
on it got worse so 2021 in a Red Bull
circuit I went to the finals where I
found out about an hour before the
finals that there was a mail in my
division yet again and this time similar
to the contest in Illinois I play second
I also lost out on thousands of dollars
with prize money this athlete took 5
brand of the prize money men for female
athletes not only placing personal in
this division but also taking the prize
for best trick
and I knew this was wrong
but it was intimidating to speak out
about it but as time went on and my
emails for Red Bull were ignored and the
concerns I had raised to the judges were
ignored I realized that
if I didn't speak up nobody would and I
had seen other female athletes speak up
in other sports during
that if they could do it I could do it
and I knew that my story was not unique
but a lot of these stories we don't even
hear about so the few that you're
carrying today are of many
but um I'm very grateful to be here
today it's an honor to be here and I'm
grateful for everyone who's fought to
reinstore fairness and equal opportunity
in women's sports when I was a child
growing up playing sports in school I
never had to worry about this
but unfortunately fairness was brought
for me as an adult but I refused to be
the last generation of girls to
experience equal opportunity respect
fairness and even safety in many sports
and finally I am happy to say we are
headed back in the right direction
these are just three of the most
courageous women but for all the young
women out there
I want you to know this we've heard we
will fight for you we will continue to
fight for you we kept our promise last
year we pledged
we had the opportunity to be in the
majority we would bring this bill
forward we can stand up for fairness we
stand up for you we stand up for Title
IX that's exactly what we did today we
asked others across this country to join
with us to help us pass into the Senate
and give it to the president's desk so
every woman is protected In fairness
Republicans
yeah he works through a committee the
Supreme Court has made that decision it
goes to the states do you personally
support
assistance signs yes on this topic
there's a misconception
transgender
people who don't know them and I want to
ask you all this is an open question
well this is a question for the long
night all right
but your question to us right there is
that you're saying
that may see this doesn't know that but
that's what you have said in your
question so far she hasn't asked her
question yet you know what it's not your
price
I will take the questions and I'll
decide when they ask the question I'll
decide when I answer
Ed I'm sorry
[Applause]
yeah and this is this is not the point I
would say we know that we understand
them it doesn't have to do with it what
it plays is this is happening this is
Athletics okay when I grew up in
athletics and I wanted to wrestle are
you on the box is based on your weight
even though we were both biological
when we went and played football we had
to weigh in every single big day why
because they wouldn't have somebody and
when we were younger over 150 compete
with some of that's 100 pounds because
you know what muscle mass made a
difference
there's a difference in volleyball why
would you have an men's sport to
volleyball seven inches higher net than
below so we can understand the other
person we can go to dinner with the
other person we can hang out with the
other person but there's a reason why
Title IX was created there's a reason
why there's men and women
there's a reason why there's a
professional basketball for men and
women it's about fairness and if there's
one final
fiber of America
it's about giving people an opportunity
that they work hard they sacrifice
listen to Macy talk a few times
she didn't go to it
not because she wasn't asked because she
made a decision she was going to
dedicate her life and her time to excel
in the sport
that she would take weekends away that
her family would sacrifice and spend
their money to drive her hours away to
compete and that moment where she can
compete where she had spent years
for colleges around the country to see
that she can grab a scholarship that all
that time away was going to pay off why
because she could have that college paid
for because of what the sacrifice she
made where others would not make that
decision
to a biological man who steps in who
that all time that he slayed he now gets
to play with the next seven inches shirt
how many basketball players would love
to play with the hookah
so it's not about whether do we know
somebody yes we do this
and then when we know and we also
understand biologically they're
different and it's about muscle mass and
about fairness Mr Mr Speaker yes
question for you your colleague Brian
Fitzpatrick has introduced a universal
background checks bill is that something
that you would support would you bring a
vote to the floor about that I I haven't
read the bill but just like any other
Bill like this deal bills go through
committees and after the bills go
through committee it's just like I said
she worked the process and the bills go
through committee that's a measure that
has the support of like 80 to 90 percent
of Americans do you support that do you
support that I answered your question
yes
I think we're in very good shape we just
rolled it out yesterday we're working
talking through all the members I don't
want to break all expectations I want
you to follow it I want you to be on the
floor I want the anticipation I want you
to see what you see is the clock goes up
I want you to write stories like I'm
teetering whether I could win or not the
whole world hangs in the balance and
then I want you to write a story after
it passes with the president sit down
and negotiate just like we've done every
other time before with the Senate are
they going to take up another bill to
name the next month maple syrup are they
going to honor the Yukon team that they
won a basketball tournament or will they
sit down and work for the American
people I mean I don't know what the
month of May will be about in the senate
or what they'll honor but I think the
honor honor the American public and
actually take up with us
the current makeup of the Senate are you
concerned at all that we'll be back in
the same position come June if the house
passes the suspended over to the center
you know someone asked me that question
when we were trying to defend
everybody's safety here at DC we put a
bill on the floor to stop them from
decriminalizing
you know what it passed the Senate the
president signed it same thing happened
without the pandemic so I shouldn't have
to worry about the Senate I'm just
worried about the Senate actually
working I'm just worried about the
Senate actually showing up but if they
show up is it going to be another month
naming name the maple syrup for March
these are going to be another month like
this week where they named UConn
basketball honoring them for winning or
will it take up the issues that America
cares most about
they've got inflation going because the
Democrats added six trillion dollars
every poll will show you Americans do
not want you just to lift the debt
ceiling and continue to have inflation
they want us to be less dependent upon
China they want us to pass it's the
exactly what we're doing they want us to
be able to protect Social Security and
Medicare so when we do work requirements
it helps more people go to work more
people to pay in
that's the concern they have now I can't
worry about the Senate I worry about the
Senate leader and Schumer whether he can
do it or accomplish but he hasn't shown
that he's done much I just wish he sits
down be able to do something so that's
why I taught the president I don't
understand he's the first president in
the country that can bumble his way into
a default or should he sit down and
negotiate like everybody's done before
Christmas
do you have any concerns about Clarence
Thomas accepting yes
immigration and border security bill
when can we expect tax to come to the
house floor you know the the leader does
that but you'll find even today Homeland
homeland's marking up and
next week and then you'll find uh I
believe in may you have a real concern
of what's happening at title 32 going
away we've got to take actions and I
thought that was a big success last
night Judiciary I give everybody
involved especially the leader and the
Whip and everybody else working on this
from chairman Jordan and everybody else
involved with Mario and Juan ciscomani
and everybody I think
what's your response to people who say
that Democrats specifically to point to
the fact that Trump also raised the debt
dealing with any president you know what
that's a great question because I think
there's a misconception of Albany
because I was actually in the room that
debt ceiling didn't get raised without
negotiations the difference is the
Democrats wouldn't raise the debt
ceiling into a president Trump agreed to
spend more money so if you watch when
the debt ceiling got raised what
happened
it all got more spending going through
with the agreement for the
Appropriations to spend more and then
when the Democrats took over overall and
had the house set in the presidency they
added six trillion dollars then what
happened next inflation
which took away
thousands of dollars from every single
American
so what we're simply trying to do
exactly what everybody else in all these
times to sit down and negotiate just as
you have to do in your own kitchen table
and just to explain it to American
public a debt ceiling is giving your
child a money card they charge it up and
they hit the limit would you simply
raise the limit why would you first sit
down and look at what you're spending
your money on every household does that
and Congress should do the same I hope
you all have a great weekend thank you
please subscribe